[Music]
we here married nothing went wrong even
my mother behaved herself he set eyes on
me for the first time hello hello
and I saw a man who wasn't wearing a
jacket nonsense
oh yes and trousers with amend and the
knee did you think then it was love
sorry man that girl actually I'm a
little bit scared what does his father
do you mean is he working class or one
of us that's more or less what I mean
you don't seem quite as happy as you
should something's bothering you Flo
come on Flo it's easy just point and
choose something about yourself little
delicate but sex man who says women are
like doorways men can enter through them
God's sake flows how long have you been
there I thought I just lost your
question damn it they all right I'm
feeling rather sick
what is it darling nothing
[Music]
you can change your mind
I really have to go we can never be
happy and it's all my stupid fault
have you actually forgotten that we were
married today
we're man and wife that's what you
promised
turn me
[Music]
it's hopeless is it
[Music]
you